i don't think these people who are
speaking on behalf of women and saying
like oh the the women's experience is
being co-opted by trans women like they
don't give a [ __ ] about women like
they're not fighting for women's rights
they're using this because it's
something that is effective in the
culture awards
bridget fantasy welcome to the show
thank you for having me we were just
talking about california
and the
state of
everything at the moment aren't they
just about to increase the taxes again
uh yes i believe there is
some kind of proposal on the board to
double the taxes because they're trying
to do
the first um like single-payer
healthcare system on a statewide level
for
everyone no matter your immigration
status no matter
i mean everyone basically
anyone
you get health care and you get health
care and look i think our health care
system in america is it is
uh
a disaster of epic proportions in many
ways and if you don't have help
navigating it or you're not rich it it's
challenging and it's bankrupted people
and
there's no transparency you just you
don't you know something has
there's no like clear-cut cost it's like
if you have insurance it costs this if
you have cash maybe you can get it for
this and
it feels very crazy to me so
um in terms of like and then like mental
health care you know just you can't get
if you move states you can't see the
therapists that you're seeing in the
other state if they're not licensed and
all this occupational licensing which is
insane and
it just um
it seems very
overly complicated one of the things i
noticed while i was out in austin was
the the homeless people that were there
like american homeless people have
another level of crazy to them so we
have homeless here in the uk you know
but
i've been around a lot of homeless
people i work in nightlife so i've been
the only people out at 2am uh club
promoters people in parties and the
homeless they've been around them an
awful lot unsupervised on the street
maybe when they've had a bit to drink or
whatever else
but walking just down the street in
austin near an underpass
and
these
guys will be talking to themselves
they're pushing something along they're
really sort of jittery and forthcoming
and aggressive it made me i don't get
nervous around people very much but yeah
there's another
like level of crazy
now imagine being a pregnant woman
walking around a city like that
um and it's everywhere yeah there's
another it certainly seems to me like
that's been aggravated as well
i don't know if it's the drugs i don't
know if it's
um
the society
a combination of all those factors
but the
number i there is not a single day that
goes by that i don't walk my dog and
or go out and do errands and have to
kind of
invade someone evade or or cross the
street or
completely reroute from someone who's
clearly talking to themselves
you're like i don't know i don't i just
i don't know
does it matter where you go is this
pretty much across most neighborhoods
now in l.a
uh yeah it's pr it's everywhere i mean
some better than others obviously i'm
not i'm not living in a gated community
and even those communities are being
affected by like armed robberies and
things that were kind of unheard of
so they're getting more
i think um like robberies car break-ins
and
uh violent crime that's happening
perfect time for double taxes yes i know
yes i know
so yeah it seems kind of crazy to me we
were talking about this on dumpster fire
my dumb
little like whatever it is show
and
we were saying like is this just a way
to punish the people who have stayed in
california
you didn't heed the signs idiots
hey idiots if you need another reason i
know and it's so hard as you know i'm a
small business owner now technically
and
it's hard i i just with payroll taxes
and the actual taxes and then yesterday
we got a letter from ladwp which is our
water and power and these these
companies operate like
um mafias because they have no
accountability and no competition so
they get to just do whatever they want
and they're like oh you
your water was in like this category for
one month out of 12 months and we're
just letting you know that
water is going up if you're in this
category and
they don't
they don't
have any resources devoted to collecting
water like this is the gut they've
caused this problem and they they pass
it off to
their
the people who are using water and they
should be [ __ ] me
it's craziness yeah and there's nothing
again no transparency you don't know
like
where that water is coming from or
what it's just it's craziness it's
and the
yeah i mean don't even get me started on
like the grids burning all the
the forest down and literally nobody is
accountable for that ever
we were saying about how crazy it is
that certain people leave you realize
there's people that have been in certain
cities for their entire life malice
leaving new york for me that was the
biggest red flag that anyone could have
waved because that guy was in love with
that city oh that's like um
carol markowitz as well i don't know
that she's another person she's a writer
and uh um she was at the new york post
and she she was like the die-hard new
yorker i mean she really
again like
comes from a russian family very much
like malice i think they know each other
and she was just
in love with brooklyn and new york and
when i would see her there she would
take me to all these cool spots and she
just
absolutely loved that city and they left
for florida and i was like i'm you know
if you have stock in new york you should
be selling it right now
so bad yeah i mean like for michael to
leave that said pretty much everything
that i needed to know
but it's
everything that i see i'm not in these
cities right i haven't been to la in a
couple of years i've been to new york in
a couple of years oh i'm going to be
there in a couple of weeks actually so i
guess i'll get to see a little bit on
the ground
i think why
why would you let the city get to this
stage like if if it's people that like
podcasters and
normal people
tweeting on the streets if they have a
problem with it let alone the public
policy people that are supposed to
actually have aspirations for these
cities
why why why is it they don't care do
they not know what they're doing is it
negligent is it malignant is it
malicious
i i don't actually know because
i would have an answer and then a lot of
other people would have a different
answer they would say
um i would say i think it's a
combination of incompetence
overcompensation
um
in california new york these are single
rule you know single party
ruled states where there dominantly
is no balance or competition
so there's
very little
it's all just progressive policies and
you know michael michael schellenberger
does a really great job i think of
recently looking at how these
progressive policies however
well-intentioned they might be
um
are destroying these cities and i'd
prefer to try and
give people the benefit of the doubt and
and say
these
come from good intentions although if
you're
on the right wing and in certain
factions of it you'll say this is part
of it they like in in an attempt to
achieve some kind of utopia
you've got to let some cities burn and
some people die and that's just part of
the process so it's it's like
this
from
from a right-wing kind of
perhaps hyperbolic perhaps not
perspective
this is what communism does goddamn
globalists man
you're done [ __ ] against commies it's
those commies and you know we joke and
call it camifornia
and
it's it's
it's
funny because it's kind of true
so
and i don't know enough about these
things i just don't i can only observe
it from like a working class perspective
man on the street and
you know that the idea that people can
just move is
also one that i
bristle at sometimes when people are
like just move just move i'm like it's
not that easy for everyone to just up
and move
if you have family in in this town if
you're not wealthy it costs a lot of
money to move
these other places where you might move
to are
now
like austin's not cheap anymore it's
certainly not
as cheap as it was many years ago
and
do you want to pay
exorbitant amounts to move and be away
from your family
and you're moving to a place usually
that has
you know not as great weather i mean
there's always a cost-benefit analysis
you're making but
i also think that's kind of like an
upper-class solution and the working
class doesn't always have that mobility
or ability
or just disposable income
so when people are like oh you're in
california just move i'm like well okay
i'm not a millionaire you know i'm not
i'm not in that we we're about to have a
child my mother-in-law lives here
if i move somewhere do i dis
dislodge my
self from like my whole system of
support which is invaluable would you be
able to take your staff with you as well
um they would come yeah i mean it's
really just my cousin it's not like um i
have this ginormous staff either like
some of these other companies that have
left la um
and
so yeah i think that would that's not
really a problem we're still pretty like
lean and mo and
mean but
it's more just the things that you can't
really put money on you know
if i move to like texas for instance
which we are thinking about
i now have no family support no i'm now
needing to pay for health care i'm
paying for a move
i'm
like not a huge fan of the weather down
there i know people are like oh it's
fine i just always jo i'm like don't
ever take advice from rich people about
this stuff when they're like it's fine
you won't even notice i'm like you have
a pool
you have like a central air conditioned
pool house like with boats and you know
i'm not
i'm not in that same league i'm gonna be
in just like some freaking house on the
flatlands and the outskirts
uh i don't have the same resources
available to me to make yeah i like my
my neighborhood would probably be the
neighborhood where the
the grid goes down and the ice storm
yeah [ __ ] people had some mad stories
about that while i was out there talk to
me about talk to me about being pregnant
are you super duper pregnant now is this
like um i'm 27 weeks so we're
approaching the third trimester pretty
big pregnant then
yeah we're in it we're uh we're deep in
the deep in the woods but not quite in
the third trimester it's
it's a trip man as like somebody who's a
drug addict i was joking the other day
that it's a good thing i didn't do this
when i was younger because i probably
would have gotten addicted to it just
because it's such a trap
like especially now that i can feel her
and she's like it's just so wild i'm
like the and
the thing that i've been tripping out
about a lot probably because i've been
listening to so much alan watts is how
effortless it is like i'm not doing
anything i'm not doing anything there
are things i'm not doing to
you know like not drinking not smoking
trying to drink enough water making sure
that i take my multivitamins but aside
from that
this
you're just along for the ride as much
as she is and you read about what's
going on and it's like what the [ __ ]
like how
she's down there just like learning her
motor skills and her eyes are starting
to blink and her hair is turning to
color and i mean it's it's really wild
the whole process every week where it's
like this is the week that blah blah
blah happens
and at first my husband was just like i
don't want to hear it i don't want to
hear about how she's like got a tail
um in the early days and now it's wild
you know i feel like
tickling me from the inside and kicking
and punching and
it feels very
it's just wild it's really a crazy
it does all
it does and then it reminds me like we
all started out this way and we were
these helpless little babies and
and just seeing how dangerous pregnancy
is and
you know i've been thinking a lot too
just about how i was never really that
interested in
like i wasn't the kind of woman that
bond over babies that got was um like
who would see a pregnant woman and be
like oh my god and feel so longing and
i would be like that looks uncomfortable
as heck and um
wouldn't really listen when like my
siblings and sister-in-laws and friends
would talk about their pregnancies and
they'd all get together and they'd have
this shared experience and i'd be like
like tune out even now last night the
the girls in my like virtual
mommy mommy support group that just kind
of happened organically from my fantasy
community actually which was amazing
um
they were talking about diapers and i
was like i really can't express to you
how much i hate shopping like i just i
hate it so much
thank god my husband is the consumer in
the family but i hate it i've hated it
for myself i hate it for
it's not something i can so when people
are like what do you think about huggies
versus pampers well we like this but i'm
like i'm i my eyes just checking out and
then i regret not listening because i
know that that information [ __ ] need
that you're gonna be asking for it in
six months time guys i've got these
huggies in this pampers discussion going
on here yeah i mean of all of the drugs
that you've taken estrogen and oxytocin
are [ __ ] progesterone yeah
swimming in it
lines your progesterone in the morning
it's so wild it's definitely
and it was such a surprise and i think
i'm still a little bit in shock and
a lot of stuff comes up just emotionally
um
because of your hormonal but also just
fears and
um
wanting i i really have also been just
focusing on like how
scary it is to allow yourself to want
something
i just don't generally i'm so
superstitious of like joy and good
things and that's a hippie in you
it's also just my upbringing was kind of
dysfunctional so i'm like the you don't
get too comfortable because the rug is
always getting pulled out from
underneath you and i think this is a
very common
experience of people who grew up in like
fight or flight constantly and
um a lot of uncertainty and stability
and dysfunction
and
you just are like people who grew up
with alcoholic parent you're always kind
of waiting for the other shoe to drop
because inevitably it always would
and
in some ways that has prepared me
exceptionally for
being on platforms like youtube for
example
and
saying things that might be beyond them
yeah yeah i'm like
this is like my upbringing any minute
now somebody might kick me out
um
and
in other ways it it kind of
robs me of allowing myself to experience
joy in the present moment because i'm so
worried that you know this bad thing's
gonna happen or like i don't deserve it
or i don't
um
yeah that's that's been like a constant
struggle it's trying to be like
because there's all this also talk where
like you need to like do a meditation
and just like
envision the baby in your arms and that
seems kind of like magical thinking to
me a bit where
it's like so if something happens that's
somehow meditating the medical problem
away
yeah
that's the um that's the brutal thing
about
one of my friends calls it uh negative
personal development that
you often put problems that you have at
the feet of you not trying hard enough
it's like it's the other side of agency
so we we don't want people to have a
victim mentality right we want them to
believe that they can do things that are
going to impact their life look you have
control over some of the outcomes but
also if the people who succeed are
worthy of their successes
what does that mean about the people who
didn't succeed are they worthy of their
losses is somebody that gets into a car
accident when someone else hits them and
they're disabled for the rest was that
was that like their fault so there's
this brutal sort of double-sided thing
to a meritocracy
yeah talking about fears as well aubry
marcus i spent a good bit of time with
him while i was in austin he's got this
awesome video to clip from when he
released his first book and he's stood
up there talking in front of a big crowd
and he's saying
people ask me if i could go back what
would i change and the only thing that i
would change i would do nothing
different but i would fear less he said
i spent so much of my time when i should
have been eating a sandwich or playing
foosball or kissing a girl
worried that i wasn't going to get here
the place that i was coming anyway how
many hours and days and months did i
waste worrying that i wasn't going to
get right here right now the place i was
going to arrive at in any case and
that's the weird thing you the neuroses
and your fears they take you out of the
present moment but i don't think they
really contribute to where you're going
like look i'm probably gonna get the
outcomes that i get in life no matter
how i think about them my programming
and
talent or lack thereof is going to
probably get me to the place that i end
up at
and all that i get the only difference
about me fearing is that i make myself
miserable in the interim between now and
then
yeah and i think too there's so much
kind of magical thinking in this in
in the new age
like love attraction
um
because to a certain extent your
thoughts do create the world you it is
there is a balance of
making sure you know there's that that
idea of like what you focus on
what you feed lives and what you starve
dies
um i i'm a big believer in like not
invoking things you know it's just funny
how you'll be cruising along and then
have uh
um
it's just funny how you can kind of
invoke these things from your past that
you might have put behind you just by
like speaking about them and then
suddenly that person appears
and you're like ah i never should have
like had a conversation with my sister
about you because now here you are [ __ ]
off uh yeah i just i put back in the box
i'm always like put it in a box and
smother it um
you need to kill that those things that
aren't necessarily healthy or toxic and
but then there's this whole concept of
like again this magical thinking as if
this thing that's happening so
effortlessly inside of me
with effort obviously but truly kind of
just
in the way
in the way a flower would bloom like
it's just this you can't i can't force
it i can't rush it there's very little i
have to do with the process much of it
is genetic it's like
when i first was pregnant i was so
nervous i i
was five weeks and it was like basically
a non-viable sack and i said to the ob
like how do i make it stick and she was
like honey if i knew that i'd be a
billionaire on a private island it's
like yeah no [ __ ] of course you would be
that's a dumb question
um
because so it's completely random and
out of control and to think that me
it's it's like my therapist says
that that fear that negative fear or
that fear of like
um
i need to think positively about this or
if i'm too excited about this i'm
somehow going to jinx it is some a way
of me trying to control something i have
no control over
and she's like it's magical thinking you
know there's there's and there's a lot
of it in
in the kind of like
laws of positivity and as if as if you
could just like
think your way out of cancer or the you
know putt and there but again there's a
lot to be said for the power of positive
thinking
but it's a very it's a very tricky
balance i think and it's it's trying to
be in control of something that i'm not
in control of at all and that's
unsettling to me but on top of that
celebrating motherhood is a
weird thing right now it's quite rare
you can't even say mother
oh yeah [ __ ] you can't even say mother
like that's the kind of weird time we're
living in where mother is like a word
that is certain have they no mothers
i haven't seen mother get cancelled oh
no that's they're trying to get rid of
that word too what do you say instead
um
like a a person i don't even know mother
is seen as like a you know cis hetero
way of viewing
uh interesting
but yeah it's not it's not celebrated
motherhood doesn't seem to be like an
admirable thing that girls uh pushed to
go and do i mean do you looking back on
your 20s and 30s now you know on the
cusp of
being a mum do you see that three by the
way yeah geriatric mom technically yeah
uh do you see it is different do you see
your 20s and 30s like in a different way
at all
um
yes
i i although i was making choices that i
was pretty aware of in my 20s and 30s so
i had
i'm the oldest of five and my siblings
were all
um they're in kind of smaller towns they
have families they have kids they're
blue collar
kind of working class um and
very rewarding fulfilling lives
and i i came to the city i was very
ambitious i was you know had a lot of
goals and dreams and aspirations and um
i think i knew
i was
i had to make these choices kind of
along the way
where i really believed i had to choose
between family or
success
like this was some
i don't think it was i don't think look
i think looking back for you to answer
your question in my 20s and 30s
that was a false belief that i couldn't
have a family and also be a successful
creative artist
i dated a guy in my early 20s and he was
like 20 years older than me but i always
called him my picasso he's a brilliant
artist and he was
so self-disciplined and kind of
would
constantly reiterate to me that like
family would get in the way of being a
successful artist and
i think i really internalized that
because he was so successful but so
solitary and alone
and
i don't know if he internalized that
from his father who wanted to be an
artist and had a family and could you
know it's like some i'm sure it was
passed down
and really just looking at a lot of the
writers and artists that i admired they
seemed like they were insanely
self-absorbed it seemed like that's what
it took
and i didn't want to be
a mother or even a wife to
and be
taken i would end up resenting the kid
and my husband so i thought
um i didn't think i thought it would
take away from all of that
so looking back
i don't think i there was any kind of
like illusion
even in my 20s and 30s i i just knew i
was making that choice
but
it's a false choice
that's that's what i've come to learn
how do you mean
like i i have a loving husband who's so
supportive of what i do and
in fact enables me to feel even braver
going out into the world
and helps me around the house in ways
that make it possible for me to
thrive and
is a as a
co-creator with me and not just like my
cr our creativity my creativity but also
in our world you know like just in our
house and
um
and now we have a child and i thought
that would
overwhelm me and take away but i think
it's again like when i was waiting
tables all those years i would have like
two
hours here and there to write and
there's a sense of urgency that i
have been not devoid devoid of the past
three years because i'm still very busy
but i certainly don't have that pressure
of like you only have two hours today to
write so i've just found myself already
writing more and i i think that
having that um and like she inspires me
to want to do more to to work harder so
i think it i
i was looking at it as just like an
all-negative and it's really actually
something that's added so much
to
my whole experience as an artist and
create creative well it's rare to think
that a woman would have chosen her
career you know you've had to have been
for almost all of human history a very
particular type of woman to have elected
to go after a career as opposed to a
family and i wonder now we've been
talking about this a lot on the show i
wonder now how many
women are kind of sold a lie
by
whatever culture dominant culture it is
at the moment that no you can be a boss
[ __ ] and clap back you don't need to
settle for less you can you know fulfill
your life with
money and status and education and cats
and
[ __ ] three houses yeah
and to then find out that they've
missed out on getting a family or you're
finding a partner or
doing whatever
yeah that that conversation is so
vast you know there's so many and i've
been
i've thought so much about these things
and now being 43 and being
because i would bristle against this
idea that like you're worthless without
a child as a woman and on the right wing
this is like a pervasive
kind of mentality that seeps into a lot
of the stuff that i started reading when
i fell into the culture wars and i was
writing a playboy so
you know when people are like oh you
know why aren't you like fully on the
right if you've left the left and it's
like i saw the way they talked to me
when i was a playboy like i don't i
don't i don't think these people who are
speaking out against speaking on behalf
of women and saying like oh the the
women's experience is being co-opted by
trans women like they don't give a [ __ ]
about women like they're not
fighting for women's rights they're
using this because it's something that
they can
that is effective in the culture awards
but like these are people who would
happily say that women belong in the
kitchen and having babies and
jokingly will say some of us don't even
shouldn't even be voting so i'm not
exactly buying that like this is out of
some concern for women um
and so it's i think it's complicated
because i don't want women to feel like
that should because for all of human
history women didn't have a choice
they just did not have a choice when you
read and learn and like
historically being a woman was [ __ ]
and it was it just was forever you had
no choice you couldn't get an education
you were property you had no right in
the public space you were
gent you couldn't fight back if you were
raped by her husband or anyone really um
with with
obvious circumstances that
are generally racist and toned
like then then there's then there's that
whole aspect like it's just been an
absolute
crap show for women
and only
which is why i do push back so hard
against this idea that like
trans women are women and can swim
against us and swim meets because i'm
like we just got these right no they
swim against each other they don't swim
against women we just got them like 50
years ago
it's not even like we've had them that
long and by the way only not not only
like the whole world hasn't experienced
this i've been to india and egypt and
cultures where
it's still very actually patriarchal and
so
um
[Music]
you're hiding under veils and you're
you're not allowed to dance in the
streets with the met i just like bananas
you're still getting stoned if you
if you are guilty of adultery and like
this stuff is still happening and that's
what it was actually like for most women
so
i have a lot i mean the name that we're
giving my daughter is matilda and
we've been researching people are like
oh you have to read about this queen
matilda in england and apparently she's
like the first woman who ever challenged
the patriarchal lineage of the throne in
england and i've been reading her story
and it's crazy and she was she was
erased from history basically and she
i've never heard of queen matteo exactly
and she's um
and she had a son that she essentially
like sacrificed herself she fought these
like war i mean it's crazy story
and
was raised basically and her son
in order to save
the throne for her son so that he was
able to maintain it and
instead of fighting for it for herself
and she was she was just a badass and
there have been these women
and so
i think that
then
motherhood you know took on
we had this kind of
idyllic very brief time where
um
women had rights it was like first wave
feminism
and then they were also
having children and they were starting
to work but they had just more choice
and more options
and during world war ii you saw so many
of them part participating in like
helping the country and working in
factories and coming together and they
really
started
seeing what they were capable of getting
more of an education
and
then you have kind of second wave
feminism where suddenly we're shaking
off all of the shackles of shame that
come with
generally being treated like a
baby-making piece of property for
thousands of years and
and there's an overcro correction i
think you know the
third wave feminism is basically like
throw out womanhood entirely
being a i remember i interviewed these
three women when i was writing for
playboy and i never got to do anything
with this interview and i always loved
it it was three generations of feminists
and the grandmother the youngest one was
like a woman who is all about free the
nipple she was like 19. and she was
third generate you know third
third wave feminist intersectional
feminist
and her mother was talking
and she was talking about how
she chose to be a mom and this was
during the whole like
you know 80s like
girl boss shoulder pads working girl
and all of the women were going to
careers and they all got together with
her favorite english professor
who they
all loved and looked up to
and when they were in a circle talking
about what they were doing with their
lives and she said she had chosen to be
a mother they basically like skipped
over her completely like her role was
just
not relevant or important and the pain
in her voice when she was talking about
this for making this choice
was palpable
and the grandmother then was talking too
and she said something she was like i
just think there's something to be said
for a little modesty you know in regards
to her granddaughter who she supported
but she comes from a very modest like
greatest generation culture
and it was so interesting speaking to
these women and seeing how quickly
feminism evolves in the west
and really like women are doing well we
have
more educate more it seems like we're
more of us are educated than ever before
higher earnings we're doing all right
and
in that you know i have a sister who's a
stay-at-home mom and and she's talked to
me a lot about the struggle of not
feeling like it's a valued
role in society anymore
and i think it's like the most selfless
role and it's so hard it's so hard to
run a house
and like raise children
it is just so
the day in day out monotony of being a
parent is is so
hardcore
and terrifying and it's such a long
it is a marathon it's not like a sprint
at all
and
so i think like that
it's i understand why
there's this kind of reaction to
never having a choice
ever one of the problems that a lot of
women and feminists have is that
we only just got
the opportunity to be in the workplace
and to be on a par with men
if we allow
motherhood to become too celebrated
maybe that's going to be taken away from
us maybe the opportunity for us to be
seen on a level playing field with men
almost as if you know how you said put
it in the box and forget about it
that's kind of a little bit what yeah
well motherhood's like it's just a thing
it's that that's a thing it's kind of
there but that's like the that's the
fallback option let's see if you can go
out let's see if we can make a career of
it and then if you can't you can go
and
yeah it's trying to find a balance
between
women haven't had
the
number of rights that they should have
done for quite a long time and they've
just got them
but has the baby and the bathwater and
the motherhood all been thrown out
together so that that's no longer
celebrated because there's you know if
we're going to keep the population going
we need to have mothers and there's this
yeah sorry go on just this huge concerns
about population collapse at the moment
that's what elon tweeted about not long
ago and if you look at the numbers it's
not that unlikely this is a [ __ ] mad
stat that one of my friends told me the
other day we could be close
to being on the planet with the largest
number of humans that are ever going to
exist
ever but but that's that whole have you
ever heard of like the 12 billionth
person or whatever there's this video
that some i don't remember i feel like
it might be associated with some bill
gates foundation but it was some kind of
study they did where it's like the 12
billionth person will never be born
because if you keep pulling people up
out of poverty
generally they stop having as many kids
so the more you raise people up and lift
them up the smaller their families get
because there's lower infant mortality
there's more opportunity people start
caring about things like population
control because they're worried about
resources they're
they have more
investment in sending two kids to
college instead of you know four that
need to work on the farm etc so
there is this idea then you see this
trend pretty much everywhere across the
world and then yes there is
rapidly declining populations in places
like japan
and the west and
it is um
you know i think in i think in
california like the only reason the
population is expanding is because of
our immigrant population generally
that's the case in most of the western
cultures
there and
so it's um
obviously something that isn't
problematic across the whole world yet
um it seems like a particularly western
problem that people discuss at the
moment
and
i do think the idea that
what worries me
and what i've really
been thinking a lot about obviously
lately is
the ways in which i felt i was lied to
by the culture by the west my western
culture because i i want to be clear i
think this is a particularly western
um like ideal and particularly western
feminist ideal where
um
like i could sleep my way to
kind of empowerment which has not
necessarily been my experience as
someone coming from trauma low
self-esteem and addiction
i don't think that that was the right
pathway promiscuity was not the path to
peace
although i should write that book
and
the idea that it seems reactive now to
me this idea
because
i've felt that reaction when someone's
saying like you aren't you know like
they're the gavin mcginnisses of the
world who are basically like your
ovaries are gonna dry up and you're
going to be an angry 40 year old and
you're going to be worthless and then
you're going to be
mad and you're going to go insane and
one time i was talking to gavin he's
like women who were 40 or go and say i'm
like well you've never met my mother
then like she has five kids and she's
freaking crazy like
crazy isn't limited to a women
b women without children and see
like 40 year old women who have dried up
ovaries or whatever the hell you're
talking about it's just it's so
reductive to say that this is
this is the case and i understand like
people who i vehemently disagree with
about a lot of things
i guess like jill flipovich would be a
great example who's this kind of
feminist writer on the left
and she pushes back against this idea
that like you need to have kids to be
considered a woman and you're somehow
less of a woman if you don't have kids
and you don't experience motherhood and
you're not
um
you're not participating in this
biological kind of imperative
and
so i understand the reaction to it but
then i worry that you're robbing
yourself of something because you're
reacting in my case i think i was
reacting to
feeling like i had to choose between a
career and a family
feeling like um
feeling like i was reacting to some of
the more
religious and right-wing rhetoric that i
heard growing up around about women and
motherhood that was very that felt very
antiquated to me backwater was sort of
sleeping around and promiscuity your
rebellion against that
um and in many ways i mean i was also i
think a reaction to being sexually
assaulted so it was like a way to take
power back and
um uh like a shame spiral that went on
for decades and
um i also have written about just how
empowering it did feel to weaponize like
weaponize my sexuality which is why i've
always had
weird issues with me too because i'm
like
like
i've definitely used my sexuality to
manipulate men this doesn't seem like
powerful men and like
men whose lives i could ruin this
doesn't seem like a one-way street like
i'm not sure that
maybe everyone is viewing this like i i
had some agency in these in these
moments
so that was always
yeah it's complicated like i feel like i
fall in the cracks of like a lot of
these issues and
given my experiences i'm able to view
them from multiple perspectives which is
sometimes
not to my benefit i wish i could just be
like
yeah
those feminists were wrong but i'm like
they're not wrong you know that and i'm
seeing this even in the way that kind of
women are being erased now with this new
like
i i don't know derek is i think the [ __ ]
word like radical feminist uses trans
misogyny you know where you're seeing
this kind of
and i joke about this all the time like
the patriarchy's so crafty they'll turn
themselves into women
so that they can stay on top
like
women got to the top
and then men were like yeah no that's
not happening we're
we're gonna we're gonna ascend again
and so there
and then seeing how much like women
fought for
and also just like the right to have
some agency and like their reproductive
health and their
health at all
and still just the areas where
like
black infant mortality rates are still
disturbing maternal mortality rates
there's still huge discrepancies and
in that kind of care all over the world
um
so
it's not like women are just killing it
like all over the world they're being
sold into sex slavery covet has
exacerbated a lot of these problems
domestic abuse
we know there's how many women get
killed every year by like a partner or
somebody that they were with
it's it's all tragic i know the uk is
having a big problem with a lot of like
violence against women
and
i just i'm like women have like borne
this
the
like humanity on their backs and in
their wombs for
the entire span of our whole entire
history and
i have a lot of compassion for people
who fight for rights for women
and i worry that that baby will be
thrown out with the bathwater as we
react to the
like
feminist you know feminists because now
i see the backlash swinging the other
way where it's like oh all these
feminists and this is
this is the end of the world and i you
know i loved what ian hersey ali said
when she was on my podcast you can tell
how well a society is doing by how well
their women are doing and
like the quality of a woman
do they have access to education health
care
are they how free are the women in your
culture that is generally representative
of how well your culture is doing
and is this such a thing it's too much
freedom
i mean
in in what
we're thinking about freedom from norms
freedom from not expectation but from
preaching no like pre-disposition i
never had to answer that question well
i'm just thinking like you know like
well one of the things that i'm like
would you ask out of like a white dude
well yeah i think so like if you were to
say have you ever been too free bro
i think so i think if you say if you
you're not expected to go out and get a
job you're now the guy that smokes weed
and plays xbox on the couch
but is that true
well i think that one of the things that
you would say about the modern world is
that masculinity doesn't really have a
very firm place to stand at the moment i
think that there is a little bit of a
crisis amongst men not knowing what
elements of their like typical heroic
masculine traits they're allowed to
cling on to and which ones of them have
kind of
been thrown out righteously and which
ones perhaps were baby and bath water
that went out with it as well okay so
hang on what's like what have we got
left here between
[ __ ] incels and mgtow and red pill
and black pill and sims and cooks and
only fans and soy boys like
you know there's a lot of [ __ ] moving
parts for men as well and it's not the
question wasn't like is there a limit
that should be placed on the freedom
that women have it's
trying to work out can you
can you push it to the point where
women
no longer see traditional roles as
aspirational anymore because they're
constantly looking to progress past them
and this is that you know motherhood not
necessarily being
held in high esteem very much anymore
because what's new what's more
progressive what's more recent is the
thing that just inherently gets held as
oh well this this must be the thing that
all of the women are supposed to do i
think i honestly honestly think that
between sort of like in cell culture
mgtow um and nofap you've kind of got
the men's area of the world with that as
well like look we were promised a future
that we're not going to get so we're
going to do something that is so
different to typically what we would
have done
starting a business having a job nine to
five finding finding a wife starting a
family that sort of stuff you get these
sort of culture counter culture and
that's the dynamic that you're talking
about right swinging between left and
right um yeah it seems more like a
cop-out to me having experience with all
those groups though it's like oh so
things aren't going your way
like that the way i feel about that
whole group that you just described and
i have a lot of compassion for them
because i really try to
even as cruel and horrific as they've
been to me in the past is that
um
welcome to the thunderdome [ __ ] like a
lot of us have been fighting for scraps
and having to compete in a
meritocracy but still
not having the same access i've been
around plenty of boys clubs my life they
do exist it helps when you can go golf
and and talk about business like there
are things that just get done and people
want to deny that and act like that's
not true and i'm not
really one to like throw again i think
words like racism and sexism in this
kind of world get thrown out and now
it's like they still exist these things
these concepts do exist they're overused
and i think we we have destroyed the
meaning of those words but it's not to
say that
people haven't been fighting against
these things and rightfully had to
fight against
um
you know the the uh
fallout from that years and decades and
generations later
and so suddenly this like crew of men
who's like we don't we're like okay you
can still go start a job i didn't get
everything i wanted and i still had to
like pick myself up
and figure it out you know i i didn't
start like murdering men
like i just don't
it feels like a little bit of an excuse
to me
like oh these feminists aren't sleeping
with us so we're gonna go shoot some
women or like
go whatever like i it just feels like uh
that feels hypo hyper reactive to me you
know
i don't see like feminists
um there's a lot of issues i have with
modern feminism that i could that i have
taken them to task for but i still don't
see women being like
well i guess we're gonna give up and
just sit on the couch and finger myself
for the rest of the day wait because we
don't have that option i don't have that
and i also disagree that that's
necessarily the case and i've only had
to learn this because i've i've raged so
hard against like trust fund babies for
example and i'm always like i [ __ ]
hate trust fund babies because i grew up
around them and
i find them intolerable often but i've
learned because i've had to
um
have a lot of compassion they didn't ask
to be born into those circumstances any
more than somebody who was born into
poverty being born into immense wealth
and it comes with a lot of its own
problems and dysfunction and craziness
and now
a lot of those kids
are messed up obviously but so are a lot
of poor kids and so are a lot of middle
class kids a lot of them take that
opportunity and they grow and they do
stuff with it and they don't have to
work a day in their life
and they still do i know so many people
who have taken the opportunities
of their inherited wealth and family
names and they've built upon them for no
reason so i think that's a really
interesting point to make that
the
how unpopular of a viewpoint is it to
say
trust fund babies they're the ones that
need our compassion but those are the
ones that we really really need to think
about how hard it is to be born in the
hamptons and you know trust me i have a
lot of issues with trust fund babies i
come from newport rhode island like this
is the old this is the original
playground of the rich and those people
still exist and that but that group of
people having a conversation where you
can go look
maybe they do face some challenges maybe
this does suck for them
being able to sit with that discomfort
and not just have a reactionary response
that appears on your twitter feed or in
youtube comments no that does happen
i know
but
being able to get past that right and to
sit with that bit of discomfort is the
same thing as
the guys that are adamant that um
society is going to accept women and
give them um encouragement because their
emotions matter and mine don't or the
women that say men still have access to
the workplace and fundamentally we are
being held down there is a glass ceiling
above us it just appears in a more
subversive and invisible way now you
know that all of this there's
obvious
low resolution ways to look at an
argument and say
here is a
here is the most extreme version of this
situation that means that this
conversation isn't going to happen but
like the interesting stuff is when you
go okay so let's play both sides here
let's think about what the difficulties
are of somebody that gets born into
incredible wealth like
do you do they
get drawn into drugs and like over
partying and stuff
as much as somebody in poverty i would
probably guess almost exactly the same
probably the same well they you know
they've done these studies on depression
and they've found that the highest rates
of depression are generally in
and um are in the lower class and in
poverty essentially
and it's usually undiagnosed because how
do you even know you're depressed if
your life is just [ __ ]
you know so it's like they they just
think like well why wouldn't i be
depressed yeah but the second highest
rate is in the highest echelons because
they feel
like i have everything and i'm still
depressed
and that's interesting to me because i
think one of the things i've found from
experiencing billionaires kids
is um that
they'll never really have the
opportunity
to know
struggle which sounds weird but it's
it's like even if they fight and they'll
have their own kind of struggles but
they're not to know what it it feels
like ever to
put like
build something from the ground up out
of nothing or from very little and we
all have help and i always think about
this behavioral economics monopoly study
that i'm so obsessed with and talk about
all the time where they gave people
um
they gave people lots of money and extra
turns and other people less money and
not as many turns and then they observed
them playing monopoly and
the p and they put like balls of
pretzels in the middle of the table and
the people who had less turns and less
access and and just were started off at
a disadvantage
they their body language was reflecting
it and the people who had more were
eating the pretzels they were just more
entitled they were really cocky
they were kind of talking smack even
though they started with extra turns and
more money
and at the end of
the
game when they would interview people
the people who had extra turns and money
always attributed their win to
decisions that they made
not like
any of the extra things that they got
and
that really got me thinking about this
idea of a meritocracy and how yes i do
think in our culture like in america i
was i was married to an immigrant my
first marriage from belarus
and seeing how much access i was like if
this guy who speaks no english can like
pick himself up and come here with
nothing at 19 years old and figure it
out
i've got to be able to freaking figure
this system out too come on uh it's like
sheer entitlement for me to think that i
can't
and laziness and
so observing that from his perspective
and seeing how much he's built in the
time that he's been here
um
and so many of the
like immigrants that i know the
restaurant i just worked at these guys
came and they were literally dishwashers
and they started a juice bar and now
they have like a amazing restaurant
chain that's fantastic and these they
are the american dream they're just
incredible
and came with nothing with nothing and
that is you can't do that everywhere
that is that is something that is when
people are like it's not a meritocracy
i'm like
you really can't
do what you can do in america in a lot
of the places in the world
and people still would kill to come here
um but that being said
there does seem to be like
a general lack of awareness about
uh where where people started
and having
you know even even with my
background being
fraught with difficulties and
um
a lot of dysfunction i still had
i i still had access i
i wasn't starving you know i i'm aware
that i had a roof over my head there are
certain things i didn't have to really
think about there were other things i
did but
you just kind of are
you you deal with the hand you're dealt
i guess and that seems to be something
and then you know i love sam harris
always talking about like moral luck
and this
um
concept that you were kind of talking
about in the beginning well does
somebody who works super hard and gets
in a freak accident on their way home
and now they're in a wheelchair and it
totally
changes your life forever
um
that had nothing to do with how hard
they worked or didn't work
you know just
sheer luck there's so much of it that's
random and out of our control
and the problem i think i have with the
culture right now is that everything
feels like a zero-sum game like it's
it's
we
it's not like free markets or social
safety nets you know we need
balance we need people need help people
aren't born into the same circumstances
and we shouldn't punish them for that
that being said i don't know that
everyone deserves
just handouts
for but this is it this is for no for
nothing
you see this complicated you see this
dialogue play out in conversations like
victim mentality and victor mentality
and trying to find a balance between the
two like some people
have had a rough ride of it and right
you need to pat them on the back and
they deserve compassion and the
compassion will help them be more
effective and it's the right thing to do
in a society that has more than it needs
right
and on the flip side of that you don't
want to there was this future of fitness
article that was just put out by self
magazine that i had some things to say
about there was basically
providing like high calorie chicken soup
for the soul for people that didn't want
to go to the gym and telling them that
the gym was this scary place that they
didn't ever want to go the reason that
fat people aren't going to the gym is
not um
their weight it's internal it's fat
phobia the problem is with everybody
else you think [ __ ] right okay so
between total free market and molly
coddle everybody from
cradle to grave like
there has to be something that's in the
middle and right
i wonder
i know that you've been talking on your
sub stack recently about like social
media and and as a communication tool as
a domain what it does to the way that we
think i think that a big part of it is
that it's such a low resolution tool to
be able to have a conversation you know
twitter's what 280 [ __ ] characters or
something and you you can't get across
nuance on there you can't get across
detail you can't even get across caveats
you can get across the headline and
that's it yeah it's true and i but i
also see like the
the explosive world of podcasts
as a balance to that you know they're
they're i always joke podcasts are gonna
save the world because we're having this
conversation right now
and trying to wrestle with these things
like
feminism is important and i was the girl
in high school who was like
i
you my my
english teacher used to say you are
going to set us back like 50 years
women back like 50 years because she was
she was the first you know you always
have that like english teacher that
exposes you to feminism when you're a
young girl in the west and or someone
and she exposed us to it and was really
feminist and kind of
taught us all about it and i was like i
don't see what the problem is like why
do i want to be in the rat race i don't
want to like why can't a guy hold a door
open for me i like it i like a little
chivalry and
i don't i i'm fine with just i love
cooking like i'm fine with him going out
there making money and me being in the
kitchen and she would just like roll her
eyes
because i just thought
i was just like why do we want to do
this like why do we want to work why are
we fighting to work um and i understand
why because there's autonomy you have
financial freedom is huge
i see
you know a lot of my
female friends who are
perhaps dependent on i mean i have like
a deep fear of being dependent on anyone
um particularly financially so
there's just a lot of reasons that you
would want to be able to go out and make
your own way that i don't think i fully
understood even as a like hustler a
little 16 year old
and
and
also just
learning more about first wave feminism
getting older
seeing
like even just in this like mommy group
chat just here and
and hearing the struggles of women now
who are working
and are breadwinners often
trying to balance that and raising kids
and
the actual just
craziness of childbirth and the danger
and
raising kids in this society that's so
unstable and crazy right now and with in
a pandemic you know we're all like i was
thinking about this the other day and
it's so sad to me what's happened with
this pandemic in terms of the way it's
absolutely got all of us at each other's
throats and i seen so many of my friends
be just completely radicalized by this
thing which i understand the reasons for
it
but i think about like they were doing
this whole thing about global literacy
and how it's we in the west it's so
western focused like the conversation is
so
so focused on the west and i feel like
so much of the big picture gets left out
and they were talking about just
globally
how would take away like how this
affected inner city kids in america
or in the uk
globally the poorest countries these
kids last years and they're never
getting them back some of them last
opportunities to
get education at a time when it meant
get an education or be sold into sex
slavery you know or start working in
they're just
dealing with different challenges we
went to south africa for our
honeymoon in february
and seeing how
like if you're
already on the brink and you're gonna
get
you're gonna get pandemic will push you
over the edge it'll push you over the
edge and these countries don't have
their government printing money and
handing it out to all their citizens
it's just not that's not happening so
you're you're already on the rails of
poverty and
now tourism is done and you rely on
tourism and you i saw this when i was in
egypt right after the revolution and
this is
i don't know this is an area where i try
to be so mindful of just how
and it drives me crazy about the
conversation a lot of the time
that we are all having is that it feels
very um still feels very
privileged for lack of a better word you
know we're still
we're not even considering how this has
affected like a large
enormous population of the globe
and everybody's been affected by this
everybody every single one of us
everyone has suffered somebody some
people didn't get to see their loved
ones die people
in other countries haven't been able to
see their family in other countries
people
i the ways in which this has affected
every single person on the globe is
endless and we'll have reverberations
for decades to come
and yet we still feel like it's just
happening to us you know like that's why
everyone thinks
we're so [ __ ] connected right we can
we connected basically to everyone on
the planet and yet still some myopic
about what it is that we look at it's
only the thing that's directly in front
of us so i'm big into existential risk
right the ways the different ways that
humanity could go extinct and
permanently curtail its genetic lineage
i mean it's a miracle we haven't
given us about 50 years i'm pretty sure
it's gonna happen but
i was sure i i sure i hoped that
a global pandemic would be
it would remind us of our common
humanity right
i can't remember who it was it's one of
you your presidents that said imagine if
there was an alien race that was going
to come and destroy us all imagine how
quickly boundaries would be forgotten
and all of humanity would pull together
like that sort of one world thing that
astronauts have gone out into space
apparently have they look back and they
realize that it is so fragile it's all
one um
and i thought there was a brief period
whatever in march april 2020
where
i honestly thought that that might be
the case that this bizarrely this
pandemic could be one of the best things
that had ever happened to us because i
knew what it was like to be in
austin texas or to be in ghana or to be
in wuhan china or to be in new zealand
or whatever right everybody didn't know
what was going on everyone was fearing
for their life everyone's scared of this
invisible virus that you can't see that
you don't know where it's come from you
don't know what it's going to do
that's the most
there's never been a situation ever ever
in human history where every human on
the planet has been impacted by
something and had such a relatable
experience
and then within [ __ ]
60 days it's tiger king
and
[ __ ]
like arguments about whether it's a
virus leak from wuhan and are you
completely forgotten and maybe maybe
it's just maybe it's not possible maybe
it isn't possible to have seven billion
people with nation states and tribalism
and
individual identities and my own agenda
maybe it's impossible to have that but
briefly and foolishly i thought that
maybe we were going to be
brought together by it
in what respect um
what would that have looked like if we
were brought together
less and and maintained it so less
tribalism more of an understanding
like you said less of a myopic view of
just us you know more empathy for the
person that is suffering that isn't
directly in front of us
this was hard
well hang on if it's hard for me
then the person that's already in a
shitty situation that's in poverty [ __ ]
it must be really hard for them and the
person that i think has it all sorted
out well actually maybe it's hard for
them as well and maybe it's hard for the
person that is my
racial opposition or my ideological
opposition or my [ __ ]
commercial
competitor whatever like all of these
things um but it wasn't a big enough
dose you know if you could see the
virus like a vaccine
the dose of the vaccine was nowhere near
high enough it was nowhere near a big
enough catastrophe to bring us together
i know i always joke i always joke i'm
like it was just enough to like shut
down the economy but not so much that it
united us i'm like it's almost like it
was created in a lab just to piss
everybody off
just like do you say
[ __ ] life for a little bit yeah exactly
and like between the woof flu and
and like tick tock and
like china's messing us up [ __ ]
ruining us they don't even need to go to
war there's this thing that you put on
your sub stack that i thought was really
interesting you said we've been tricked
into thinking we need to care about
everything every birthday every life
event every social movement social media
has trained us to believe that we should
not only care we should have an opinion
it doesn't matter how far from our lane
we drift suddenly we are experts in
shipping nuclear power iran or
epidemiology even if we had to google
what that word meant just 15 months ago
because we read a wikipedia article and
watched a few youtube videos the truth
is most of us know a lot about a couple
of things and we and next to nothing
about everything else
it's so unpopular to not have an opinion
on everything
[ __ ]
i don't know i'm very comfortable not
knowing anything and i feel like that's
people joke to i i always joke i'm like
i don't know anything people you sell
yourself short i'm like no
i don't i'm not an expert in anything
there are people who are actually
experts they devote their life to
learning one thing
they know a lot about that thing
they have
they've you know focused intently on
developing a skill or a practice or
something like
i'm i'm not one of those people i know i
was joking just yesterday i'm like well
i guess i'm gonna start my mommy vlog
because the only thing i'm really good
at is like navel gazing interior
monologues
and i know me i know myself but i was
talking to my husband and i we we were
talking about this just how
um and i've talked about this before
being an addict i was like i wonder if
it's because i'm an addict and i just
fundamentally don't trust myself like
i'm hyper aware when you recover from
addiction
you are hyper aware of
your capacity to lie to yourself and
others
others in in pursuit of your addictive
behavior
and myself and just delusion
and he was talking about this quote
that he was like i'm gonna butcher but
it was something about how
um are we really learning anything new
or are we just rearranging our
prejudices to like better suit us and
and it's from some famous there but you
know psychiatrist or something
and
i was thinking a lot about that you know
are we just kind of rearranging our
biases to
be
just to
confirm what we're already kind of
believing
and a lot of these
i there's always these little like
things that pop up
and i think i'm also just very
contrarian by nature so
i was very
like i made my t-shirt you're not woke
you're annoying back in like 2018 and
now i want to take it down because woke
i'm like annoyed that i feel like woke
was being overused you know i was like
oh
this was funny like when nobody knew
what woke was but now it feels like a
right wing talking point
and
um
i've
i'm always aware of how i'm being
reactive just being like an addict
and i was thinking a lot about i've been
really just on
on it about like
how a lot of these pandemic policies
have affected the people that
ostensibly particularly the left clair
claims to care about like poor kids
who are losing years of their education
and can't go to the playgrounds and like
all the rich kids i know had tutors in
their backyards and
wi-fi and ipads you know that not
everybody has this access and generally
these things hurt the poorest always
disproportionately they're always going
to suffer the most from anything
and
so i've been raging against that for
months and months and months and
i was
i definitely
my
like left-wing idealism in the beginning
of the pandemic and i think just fear
like nobody knew what this was i was
definitely like yeah maybe we should
shut it down for two weeks and
on the right there were people who were
like this is insane they're never gonna
take i was like calm down you guys and
now i've written about it i'm like i was
so wrong
i take it back i did not realize that if
you give control to these people they
don't ever give it back and i will never
make that mistake again it was
traumatizing i think that's the lesson
[ __ ] that is the biggest lesson that so
many people have taken so i've said this
a lot i don't i don't have like a
conspiratorial bone in my body usually i
think that's very much a british thing
but i don't think about the globalist
elite and their brand plan to take the
nsa well they did this with project
mockingbird and blah blah i'm like right
okay okay cool but
i just don't i'm not usually there i'm
not usually in that mode of thinking but
holy [ __ ] if the last two years hasn't
eroded every last bit of trust that i
have not only that the people in power
and the press are acting in good faith
because they're not not only that
they're not acting competently because
they're not but also that they don't
care about being either malicious or
negligent like right it's this perfect
perfect [ __ ] blend of idiocy
and
self-serving malice
and just not not a foot given
it's that all put together did you watch
i
pulled this quote out the other day did
you watch uh don't look up
no i haven't seen it yet okay so there's
this quote in that kate dibiase one of
the scientists and she says the truth is
way more depressing so this is someone's
talking about conspiratorial thinking
there's this asteroid coming oh it's
actually a plan for blah blah blah and
people are going to use it to take over
control the truth is way more depressing
than not even smart enough to be as evil
as you're giving them credit for right
yeah i mean
that that has been
something i've really been thinking a
lot about and then this recent
conversation about like this kind of
idea like oh i'm over the pandemic you
know
that language that was popping off
lately and
and i don't know i've
i've in-laws who are nurses and stuff
like that and it just depends on where
you're sitting like that to me like i'm
over it it's like a i got mad when i was
hearing that not because i don't have
similar feelings like in some respects
i'm like well i've always been over this
on behalf of the working class because
you're saying this as someone who had a
choice about whether or not you could
work
during the pandemic like you do know
many people worked and never stopped
working and just like kept on working
through the whole thing and didn't have
a choice imagine how over it you'd be if
you were a frontline nurse yeah exactly
and imagine and i and two years in and
the numbers of people who are you know
pre it's just like i don't know what
that's like
and you're watching people die and
they're people who might not have to die
like how frustrating
i might be
a radicalized tick-tock nurse
you know
calling for joe rogan's banning if i was
on the front lines of an of a like place
that was experiencing this over and over
and i had had to personally witness like
hundreds and thousands of people die
i don't i don't i just don't and i have
as much as like the disdain i have for
teachers unions and their decisions
particularly like lausd which is one of
the most
ridiculous mafias in the world
i have a lot of compassion for teachers
that their job isn't easy they're
dealing with parents administration kids
they're generally underpaid
there's administrative bloat that's
destroying public schools they are on
freaking gofundme raising money for
supplies every year like
it doesn't seem it seems like a
thankless job that you do because you're
called to it and
and
yeah i mean it's easy for me it's easy
for me to just sit in judgment and
i
i've been really like hyper aware of
that lately i feel like
and i also feel like after years of
getting caught in the crossfire of the
culture wars
being
somewhat radicalized um
by being
rejected by what i thought were my
friends you know it's hard when your
real-life friends are
rejecting you and following you and
you're feeling consequences of maybe
having wrong think
and
i was always aware of being kind of
weaponized
on the right as like oh see this like
liberal who woke up from the
commie spell she was under why i left
the left yeah yeah that it's very i get
it it's so common and and i hear this
story every day like we our last episode
of dumpster fire we asked people to tell
us like was there a moment you were red
pilled or purple purple pilled or black
filled and um
why when was it or was it a process and
the emails i'm getting are fascinating
like their whole entire stories from
people and
this does seem to be something like
malice talks a lot about where it's just
he sees it as a positive that there's an
overall just distrust in the
institutions
from top to bottom
and i worry though because if there's
nothing
that people can grab onto
they grab onto conspiracy theories you
know they're they're going to reach for
things that aren't necessarily serving
them that are there to
weaponize and manipulate them
and
is it even a conspiracy
like every 2021 is the year everyone
became a conspiracy theorist in the
whole world
there's a so i got to tell you about
this i learned this last year um it's
called compensatory control so this is a
psychological uh effect where are we
matthew syed came up with this and he
put it in the time so i read this last
year
psychologists have conducted experiments
to shed light on why people lose or at
least suspend rationality one experiment
asked people to imagine going to a
doctor to hear an uncertain medical
diagnosis such people were significantly
more likely to express the belief that
god was in control of their lives
another asked participants to imagine a
time of deep uncertainty when they
feared for their jobs or the health of
their children they were far more likely
to see a pattern in meaningless static
or to infer that two random events were
connected this is such a common finding
that the psychologists have given it a
name compensatory control when we feel
uncertain when randomness intrudes into
our lives we respond by reintroducing
order in some other way superstitions
and conspiracy theories speak to this
need it is not easy to accept that
important events are shaped by random
forces this is why for some it makes
more sense to believe that we are
threatened by the grand plans of malign
scientists than the transmutation of
some silly little microbe
i love that i love this whole conversa i
mean that's another rabbit hole like
brene brown talks a lot about this
actually about conspiracy theory and the
role it plays in storytelling
essentially we as humans have this need
to make sense of the world and tell
ourselves a story
and in the absence of something that
makes sense or uncertainty we will we
will turn to conspiracy because it helps
us to conceive the story yeah yeah yeah
yeah and just that the human need for
a story that makes sense to them even as
crazy as it might be
and it's often just stupidity and
competence you know this is where i love
michael shermer's perspective is he's
such a skeptic
it's like
yeah just straight narrow
um
you know his the and my husband's very
much like this too where because i lean
i think i'm
[Music]
i think i indulge in conspiracy theories
because i think they're fun that's
always been my relationship with
conspiracy theories like i've said
before i i believe in past lives because
it's more interesting for me to believe
it's just a more and you can't prove to
me that it isn't real
and it's more interesting for me to
believe that i'm going to choose the
more entertaining of the two options i'm
a writer i'm gonna choose what's more
interesting to me
um
but my husband when it comes to
conspiracies he's that like how many
people would have to be in on this and
keep this a secret for it to be true
just
how what are the he's like how many
people do you know can keep a secret
like maybe one you know
it's not not many people are great at
that globalist
people wearing those [ __ ] long noses
things yeah from the big well i don't
know because where does that come from
because they're [ __ ] slipknot fans
maybe i don't know
okay i don't [ __ ] know look bridget
let's bring this home i really
appreciate you coming on where should
people go where should people go they
want to check out what you do
um
you can go to my sub stack which is
beyond parody with bridget fedesy on
it's bridgette fantasy dot sub stack or
whatever
you can go to my locals community which
is where we have a tribe
of tribalist people it is very tribalist
it's a very
wacky group and
we have
workouts for the women
and we do live streams and that's at
fantasy.com and
i put a lot of stuff behind the pay
while it's more personal
um
and also
just more my own like life and um we
also do the unedited dumpster fires
there you can find me on youtube
we have a show dumpster fire now a
podcast as well i have a podcast watkins
welcome
um
which you should come on for sure
and
you can find me a bridge of fantasy on
all social media amazing thanks bridget
thank you what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace